ce que vous venez de nous dire c'est
tenter aussi longtemps que la loi fera
pas mon affaire je ne la respecte pas
pour moi monsieur c'est inacceptable et
vous n'êtes pas celui qui va nous
imposer le modèle
comme c'était magique uber efficace
écologique de belles voitures propres
des chauffeurs bien payés et pas cher
pour les clients en plus c'est du moins
ce que les dirigeants voulaient vendre
au gouvernement Couillard et cette
semaine on va vous montrer comment ça
s'est passé en coulisses
[Musique]
le ministre responsable de ce dossier là
et ça ça se faisait dans votre dos j'ai
jamais eu personne qui a été capable de
me prouver ça vous le faites aujourd'hui
un ancien haut dirigeant révèle les
stratégies secrètes du beurre
avec les beaux discours
spartache on manipulait les règles en
place on manipulées même la démocratie
maintenant avec le recul je me rends
compte que on a menti et donc c'est pour
ça que j'ai décidé de parler ici
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
je fais du taxi maintenant ça fait 47
ans
combien d'autres immigrants haïtiens max
fruit rosalberts s'est tourné vers
l'industrie du taxi afin de gagner sa
vie à Montréal
c'était pour contre la que nous sommes
des gens qui arrivent ici et puis les
douches que nous a ouvert le bras
on était fier de faire ça de servir le
public même si ce travail ne rapporte
pas de fortune l'industrie était
réglementée afin de limiter le nombre de
taxis et assurer un revenu minimum pour
les chauffeurs
mais tout a changé avec l'arrivée du
Berre depuis 10 ans sa vie est
chamboulée par l'arrivée de ce nouveau
joueur qui a provoqué une
soucoussismique dans l'univers du
transport
que il est juste le fait d'y penser ça
fait mal
comment Hubert a réussi à prendre
d'assaut l'industrie du taxi et a
imposer son modèle une fuite de
documents interne révèle et dessous de
la campagne de l'obéine cuber a déployé
afin de conquérir le Québec et le monde
[Musique]
Hubert est une entreprise de San
Francisco qui a lancé en 2010 un service
offrant au consommateur de élire un
véhicule grâce à une application mobile
permettant à presque n'importe qui de
devenir chauffeur
de ses débuts Hubert promet une
véritable révolution du transport urbain
des engorger les villes fournir un
service à bas prix pour les
consommateurs et permettent au chauffeur
de tirer des revenus substantiels au
volant de leur voiture
mais derrière les promesses du père il y
a une autre réalité
et une attaque frontale à la
réglementation du taxi dans les grandes
villes du monde grâce à une redoutable
machine de lobbying dont un de ses
anciens aux dirigeants a décidé de
dévoiler les rouages
était le lobbyiste en chef du beurre
pour l'Europe le Moyen-Orient et
l'Afrique de 2014 à 2016 il est depuis
devenu un lanceur d'alerte
il est à l'origine de la fuite des
hubert-ferz plus de 124 000 documents
internes transmis au quotidien
britannique The Guardian qui les a
partagé avec le consortium international
des journalistes d'enquêtes et
Radio-Canada
bonjour Frédéric nous avons rencontré
Marc Mégane et j'étais au cœur de
l'équipe qui dirigeait uber dans le
monde donc j'ai tout à fait ma part de
ressentialité maintenant avec le recul
je me rends compte que on a menti et
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé de
parler
Marc Megan travaillait aux côtés de
Travis scalanique le controversé
fondateur et PDG Dubert qui a dû
démissionner en 2017 à la suite d'une
série de scandale dès le départ la cible
de Travis calanic était l'industrie du
taxi
l'objectif de l'entreprise et
d'introduire son service
uber x un service permettant à tout
citoyen de s'improviser chauffeur pour y
arriver Hubert lance une formidable
campagne de lobbying auprès des élus à
l'échelle mondiale
on avait un accès incroyablement facile
au ministre
au Premier ministre président partout
dans le monde
uber c'était perçu à l'époque comme
étant extrêmement sexy tout le monde
voulait recevoir les fondateurs du bain
j'avais jamais vu
une machine de lobbying aussi bien
huilée aussi bien financé en si peu de
temps
selon ce document interne provenant de
la fuite son budget de lobbying mondial
en 2016 atteignait 90 millions de
dollars américains dont au Canada 750
000 dollars rien que pour l'embauche de
l'obéissance
au Québec Hubert recrute les services du
lobieriste François crête d'ancien chef
de cabinet d'une ministre libérale mais
l'entreprise n'attend pas d'obtenir le
feu vert des autorités pour aller de
l'avant le raisonnement du beurre
c'était toujours il vaut mieux demander
pardon par la suite que demander la
permission d'entrer sur le marché
première journée comment ça se passe
c'est parfait en fait vous êtes mon tout
premier client ah oui oui en octobre
2014 Hubert Lançon service Hubert X à
Montréal en soutenant qu'il s'agissait
là de covoiturage et non pas de taxi
c'est un nouveau service et un nouveau
produit il y a pas de réglementation
spécifique par rapport au covoiturage
citoyen comme oberex
c'était du jamais vu en tout cas à ma
connaissance c'était du jamais vu qu'une
entreprise Vienne s'implanter dans un
industrie extrêmement réglementé et
fonctionne en dépit de ses règles là à
peu près partout doit à travers le monde
c'était le même modus operandy donc
j'arrive je m'impose le jour même du
lancement du service hubertx à Montréal
le maire de l'époque de nicodère dénonce
les activités de l'entreprise américaine
et moi je pour le covoiturage mais de
faire du covoiturage avec une activité
commerciale c'est du transport illégal
même son cloche la part du ministre des
Transports du Québec à l'époque Robert
poety j'avais dit Monsieur colère que
nous étions pas pour l'accepter
quelqu'un qui arrive au Québec en se
disant j'ai pas besoin de suivre les
lois et règlement et puis je peux faire
du taxi moi comme je le veux parce qu'on
l'appelle un autre nom parce qu'on a une
application
selon un courriel interne du père
relatant le lancement du bérix Montréal
l'entreprise ne semble pas préoccupée
par l'opposition du Mercader c'était
entièrement anticipé mais nous
travaillons avec Québec en coulisses a
fait contourner Montréal
avec qui travailler
uber à Québec pour contourner Montréal
clairement pas avec moi mais moi jamais
personne en autorité dans l'entreprise
du bain qui a communiqué avec mon bureau
pour avoir soit une rencontre pour avoir
des discussions s'ils en ont eu c'est un
niveau plus élevé que le mien
quelques mois plus tard le ministre
poétique convoque à son bureau le
directeur général d'Hubert au Québec
Jean-Nicolas Guillemette je l'ai
provoqué publiquement pour venir me
rencontrer ce qui le fait dans les
semaines à venir avec une feuille de
cartable 8 et demi 11 à peine griffonner
c'était ça son dossier il y avait rien
comme projet autre que de nous dire
poliment à peine qui avait pas besoin de
la sentiment du gouvernement et qu'il
n'avait pas à suivre aucune forme de
règlement pour être capable d'opérer au
Québec honnêtement c'est une blague ça a
été la plus courte rencontre que j'ai eu
qui était tout à fait
inutile
Hubert mène discrètement sa campagne
au-delà des cercles politiques dans ce
courriel interne l'entreprise se vante
d'avoir fait des démarches pour obtenir
le soutien favorable de l'Institut
économique de Montréal qui a ensuite
parlé duber dans les médias comment vous
voyez ça c'est l'arrivée de ces
nouvelles applications très positives
images je pense que ça peut permettre à
désengorger nos routes ça diminue la
pollution
l'Institut économique nous dit avoir
prôné l'ouverture du marché du taxi
avant sa rencontre avec Hubert et que la
réduction de la pollution n'était qu'un
argument périphérique soulevé sur la
base des informations disponibles à
l'époque selon un courriel interne
Hubert a aussi rencontré
l'environnementaliste Steven Guilbaud
devenu depuis ministre fédéral de
l'environnement Guilbaud et son
organisation équitaire sont par la suite
intervenus en faveur du beurre et de
services semblables affirmant qu'il
s'agissait d'une solution pour réduire
la congestion urbaine Baine et les gaz à
effet de serre il y a plusieurs études
qui démontent que c'est faux c'est
incroyable le pouvoir de séduction des
mots des mots puisque la réalité
la réalité c'est que il y a plus de
voitures sur les routes aujourd'hui
maintenant à cause du beurre qu'à
l'époque parce qu'il y a des millions de
personnes qui conduit sur le plateforme
uber qui n'auraient pas conduit
auparavant
équitter dit ne plus soutenir uber en
raison des études qui ont été menées
depuis et des pratiques problématiques
de l'entreprise
à l'époque bien des Québécois décident
de faire l'essai du bar en raison de ses
prix alléchant mais pour les chauffeurs
de taxi dont les prix sont réglementés
il s'agit d'une concurrence déloyale qui
les frappe de plein fouet
est arrivé il donnait des discrètes à la
clientèle il leur donnait des voyelles
gratuites
du centre-ville à l'aéroport c'était 40
dollars mais il est faisait 25 dollars
c'est bas prix était loin de refléter
les coûts d'Hubert selon Marc Megan bon
l'opéra perte partout en subvention
utilisé de 10 milliards qu'on avait
levés des grands investisseurs on
utilisait cet argent pour subventionner
les rides donc le transport mais c'était
un leurre c'était tout ça c'était pour
séduire les politiques séduire les
consommateurs pour défoncer la porte
entrer sur un marché et ensuite le but
c'était de ensuite posséder ce marché
remplacer un monopole pardon
caisse fiscale donc des lois sur les
prix du beurre sont particulièrement
attrayants d'autant plus qu'à ses débuts
l'entreprise ne semble pas percevoir la
TVQ selon une enquête de revenus Québec
c'est pour cette raison qu'en mai 2015
les autorités fiscales perquisitionnent
les bureaux d'Hubert dans le vieux
Montréal et à Pointe Saint-Charles mais
en pleine perquisition quelque chose
d'inattendu surprend les enquêteurs
à 10h40 il constate aux deux adresses
que les ordinateurs les téléphones
intelligents et les tablettes
redémarrent exactement au même instant
le directeur général duber déclare aux
enquêteurs sur place qu'il avait discuté
avec des ingénieurs Dubert à San
Francisco et ses derniers avec crypté
les données à distance
c'est une tactique cuber à employer dans
plusieurs pays un outil appelé le kill
switch ou coupe-circuit qui bloque
l'accès aux serveurs de San Francisco
pendant que un logiciel crypte les
données sur les appareils
il y avait une politique une approche de
qui switch à chaque fois qu'on voyait
venir sur l'horizon
une lumière bleue ou un investigateur au
bureau
en faisait un coup de fil ou un sms on
appuie sur un bouton donc l'accès au
serveur est coupé ce qui
empêche la justice de faire son travail
à la suite la perquisition menée dans
ses bureaux de Montréal Hubert s'adresse
au tribunaux pour contester la validité
des mandats obtenus par Revenu Québec un
juge la Cour supérieure confirme leur
validité et mentionnent que le
redémarrage à distance des appareils
électroniques revêt toutes les
caractéristiques d'une tentative
d'entrave à la justice
un porte-parole de l'ancien PDG dit que
Travis scalanic n'a jamais autorisé
d'action ou de programmes qui
entraveraient la justice dans quelques
pays que ce soit pour sa part Hubert
reconnaît avoir commis plusieurs erreurs
dans le passé et affirment ne pas avoir
employé de coupe-circuit dans le but de
contrecarrer des enquêtes des autorités
depuis 2017 Hubert ajoute nous ne
chercherons pas d'excuses pour des
agissements antérieurs qui ne sont
clairement pas en ligne avec nos valeurs
actuelles
c'est souvent très souvent un jeu de jeu
de chat le chat à la souris avec le
recul c'était c'était vraiment
inacceptable
[Musique]
après la pause est-ce que la
multinationale uber était assez
puissante au Québec pour faire tomber un
ministre
pour me dire
si tu bouges pas tu vas perdre ton poste
[Musique]
quand l'ancien ministre des Transports
Robert poetic a perdu son poste au
Conseil des ministres le professeur
blanc que c'était pour passer plus de
temps avec sa famille il exprimait
publiquement sa déception vous allez
maintenant comprendre pourquoi pour lui
cette décision est intimement liée au
dossier Hubert
dans sa quête pour s'implanter au Québec
Hubert a lancé son service sans
autorisation tout en effectuant une
campagne de lobbying pour convaincre les
élus de changer les lois mais en juin
2015 leur opération de séduction se bute
à l'opposition du ministre des
Transports de l'époque Robert poetic
est-ce que si vous continuez à faire du
uber ou duber x selon vous vous êtes
illégal selon la loi au Québec
oui ou non j'aimerais spécifier une
chose extrêmement importante ici
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucun jeu au Canada
qui a statué aujourd'hui sur la légalité
ou l'illégalité double donc il est faux
de dire que c'est un service qui est
illégal vous faites tout ça en dehors de
la loi
mais c'est illégal et vous le savez
illégal
en effet en privé des hauts dirigeants
du Berte né en 2014 un tout autre
discours concernant l'accès à des
marchés fortement réglementés dans un
courriel de la fuite des hubert-ferz la
directrice mondiale des communications
estiment que parfois nous avons des
problèmes parce que bien nous sommes
fucking illégaux
parfaitement conscient mais
en jouet le jeu s'il y avait une
décision en justice contre nous on
faisait appel et en attendant l'appel
qui prenait souvent des mois à des
années en continu à fonder le service
exaspéré des chauffeurs de taxis de
Montréal s'organisent et prennent en
chasse des véhicules qui utilisent
l'application du bar
au fil des mois la tension monte
craignant les débordements le ministre
poétique convoque les représentants de
l'industrie du taxi afin de calmer les
esprits et les inciter à ce moderniser
comprenez-moi bien le statut quo n'est
plus une option viable
[Applaudissements]
je l'avais dit à l'époque était accès de
Montréal avait pas gagné une médaille
d'or là dans le service si vous
véhicules sont pas propres si vous
n'êtes pas capables de prendre les
cartes de crédit vous allez dépasser par
quelqu'un qui va être capable de le
faire je leur ai demandé de me faire
confiance et que j'étais pour travailler
pour eux dans une équité
les représentants de l'industrie du taxi
comme Max Louis rosalbert voyez en
Robert poéty un allié on a trouvé qu'on
avait une chasse avec Monsieur poésie
parce qu'on savait qu'on avait une cause
juste parce que non on misait sur la
légalité au musée sur le bon sens
mais pendant Robert poety somme
l'industrie du taxi et de passer un coup
de balai Hubert mais discrètement en
oeuvre une stratégie afin de contourner
le ministre qui lui barre la route le 6
août 2015 à 16h le directeur général
Dubert et son lobbyiste se rendent au
bureau montréalais du cabinet du premier
ministre
EZY rencontre des conseillers de
Philippe Couillard selon un document
transmet en vertu de la loi d'accès à
l'information cette rencontre s'est
tenue à l'insu du ministre poétique
vous informer ça non
je suis étonné mais moi j'ai pas été bah
non seulement invité mais je n'ai pas
participé ou je ne l'ai pas au courant
sur une base officielle là je le vois
sur le document d'agenda
le ministre responsable de ce dossier là
et ça ça se faisait dans Waldo c'est
leur choix de faire ça
j'aurais j'aurais aimé être informé de
toute évidence j'ai pas assisté à
l'ensemble des
si on rencontrait l'opposition la
résistance
on allait au dessus
de la tête de cette personne pour aller
voir le Premier ministre ou la personne
en charge pour leur expliquer que
fallait réfléchir à deux fois avant de
interdire uber donc vous voulez vraiment
vous positionner contre le consommateur
contre l'innovation technologique contre
votre avenir politique
nous avons joint le Premier ministre de
l'époque par visio-conférence Philippe
Couillard affirme ne pas avoir été
influencé par uber mais je garde pas de
cette époque là l'impression d'avoir été
soumis à des pressions de l'entreprise
je demandais aux gens de mes cabines de
mon cabinet d'avoir ces rencontres là et
vous voulez avoir une bonne connaissance
préalable des arguments incuburs pour
les apprécier à ma propre à ma propre
mesure
en plus de s'adresser directement au
cabinet du premier ministre Hubert
rencontre les dirigeants de la
Commission jeunesse du Parti libéral un
groupe qui a beaucoup de poids car il
détient le tiers des voix des
différentes instances du parti on a
notamment parlé avec Hubert qui nous ont
un peu expliqué leur modèle puis leurs
intentions Québec nous on les
rencontrerait pas nécessairement pour
être convaincu de quoi que ce soit nous
on réfléchit vraiment l'économie
collaborative de manière large et pas
seulement centrée sur uber
lors du congrès annuel de 2015 la
Commission jeunesse appelle le
gouvernement Couillard légalisé Hubert
et les entreprises similaires comment le
gouvernement c'est d'encadrer la
pratique de tous l'économie du partage
pas seulement du béret
on parle d'économie du partage mais il y
a rien de partage
juste du capitalisme pur et simple donc
je dirais que au niveau du vocabulaire
qui était employé et déployé par Hubert
il y avait toute une un narratif qui
était
erronée sur le plan factuel c'était un
leurre c'était quelque chose de
relativement factice c'était des slogans
des outils de communication pour
convaincre une partie de la population
surtout les jeunes donc les jeunes
consommateurs les jeunes électeurs les
jeunes au sein des partis politiques
à l'automne 2015 malgré les efforts de
lobbying déployés par uber l'entreprise
fait toujours face à une impasse
Hubert sera alors l'artillerie lourde et
des pêches au Palais des congrès de
Montréal son vice-président responsables
des politiques et de la réglementation
David plouf l'ancien chef de campagne de
Barack Obama c'est lui qu'on utilisait
quand on avait des négociations
difficiles pour un peu
bénéficier de l'aura de du monde Obama
et un peu attiré cette magie vers la
marque Hubert
les gouvernements qui même les plus
recalcitrants vis-à-vis de modèles
d'entreprises du bain était toujours
très content de s'asseoir avec David
love pour écouter ce qu'elle avait dit
entrevue avec Radio-Canada après son
discours David prouf est resté vague
concernant ses contacts avec les élus
québécois les dieux avec andersation
[Musique]
David plouf obtient l'échange qu'il
souhaite avec les hautes sphères du
gouvernement québécois à peine un mois
plus tard selon le document transmis en
vertu de la loi d'accès à l'information
le 22 octobre 2015 une conférence
téléphonique se déroule entre David
plouf Jean-Nicolas Guillemette et le
chef de cabinet de Philippe Couillard
Jean-Louis Dufresne encore une fois il
s'agit de discussions auxquelles le
ministre responsable du dossier n'est
pas invité
on m'a informé
qu'apparemment il y a des gens au bureau
de fraministes qui parlaient avec Hubert
de San Francisco directement avec les
grands patrons du beurre moi j'ai jamais
eu de preuves j'ai jamais eu personne
qui a été capable de me prouver ça vous
le faites aujourd'hui
[Musique]
de donner un Vig
oureux passe au transport chassant le
ministre Robert poétique sur les
banquettes arrière
quand ça s'est produit ben oui c'est un
choc vous détruire uber ou barrix c'est
pas ça je voulais juste que ceci se
fasse dans l'ordre puis dans la légalité
puis dans l'équité
ses fonctions de ministres et que vous
avez nommé Jacques Daho est-ce que c'est
à cause du dossier Hubert non absolument
pas d'ailleurs je parle jamais des
raisons pour lesquelles le ministre est
nommé ou
sort du Conseil ministre au centre de
responsabilité
les chauffeurs de texte si eux venaient
de perdre leur allier le plus important
on trouve qui se battait en notre faveur
contre un mur quand il a perdu son
emploi
il s'est sacrifié pour nous
au retour pour mieux influencer les
vieux politiciens Hubert mise sur les
jeunes libéraux
et c'est un facile de nous dépeindre à
ce moment-là comme étant des gens
rétrograde ou réactionnaires qui est pas
capable de gérer le changement
[Musique]
grâce au lanceur d'alerte Marc Megan et
au uberfalls on comprend mieux la partie
d'échec à laquelle c'est livré la
multinationale partout à travers le
monde voyons voir maintenant comment ici
au Québec l'entreprise a mis ses
opposants et chaque et mat
[Musique]
au début de l'année 2016 les activités
d'Hubert suscitent de plus en plus la
colère des chauffeurs de taxi de
Montréal
[Applaudissements]
ils organisent une manifestation à
l'aéroport Trudeau
on avait une bataille à faire mais c'est
même pas une bataille passion vous savez
qu'on ne pouvait pas perdre ce combat
une semaine plus tard au centre-ville
une poignée de manifestants lance des
œufs sur un véhicule uber
à Toronto aussi des confrontations
dangereuses se multiplient
[Musique]
mais c'est en France que la stratégie du
verbe s'imposer en dépit des lois
suscite les plus vives réactions plus de
2000 chauffeurs de taxis se mobilisent à
Paris pour manifester contre la
multinationale américaine provoquant une
réponse musclée des forces de l'ordre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
selon des textos provenant de la fuite
des hubert-ferz le PDG de l'entreprise à
l'époque Travis calanic voulait inciter
les milliers de chauffeurs uber à
commettre eux aussi des gestes
désobéissance civils malgré les risques
de confrontation je crois que ça en vaut
la peine la violence 46 succès et
critique à ses collègues dont Marc
Meghan c'était
irresponsabilité énorme par rapport aux
vies de ces choses ubains c'est facile
de les instrumentaliser alors qu'on est
au chaud dans son bureau de San
Francisco donc je trouve que c'est
immoral
selon son porte-parole Travis scalanic
ni avoir suggéré cuber devrait profiter
de la violence au détriment de la
sécurité des chauffeurs
en France Hubert faisait face non
seulement des chauffeurs de taxi en
furie mais aussi un gouvernement hostile
qui a adopté une loi très contraignante
envers l'entreprise mais Hubert a une
atout de taille son chef du labying en
Europe marque Mégane nous des liens
privilégiés avec Emmanuel Macron le
futur président qui occupe alors le
poste de ministre de l'Économie et de
l'industrie il était parfaitement
d'accord avec nos arguments en privé
était extrêmement critique de son propre
gouvernement par rapport à leur
résistance à leur opposition à uber donc
c'était un allié vraiment naturel et
c'est grâce à lui qu'on a pu continuer
nos objectifs en France
hors de rencontre secrète dans les
bureaux d'Emmanuel Macron à Paris le
ministre s'entend avec Hubert sur une
stratégie commune l'entreprise
américaine aidera à rédiger en coulisses
des amendements à une nouvelle loi moins
contraignante
donc il nous a proposé de travailler
avec ses conseillers techniques ça ne
sont cabinet ce qu'on a fait de manière
extrêmement régulière de manière très
rapprochée et en fin de compte on a
réussi à obtenir le cadre réglementaire
qu'on recherche
au Québec aussi Hubert tente d'exercer
son influence sur le processus
législatif dès l'arrivée de Jack Daous
au poste de ministre des Transports en
le jour même où Jacques Daho annonce une
commission parlementaire un dirigeant
d'Hubert au Canada envoie un courriel à
Marc Mégane intitulé discussion de la
stratégie au Québec il écrit si vous
avez un bon plan d'action pour ce que
vous avez fait en France j'aimerais
beaucoup le consulter la France est
vraiment l'exemple
d'un pays qui était extrêmement hostile
et on a un pur totalement retourné la
situation ça pouvait peut-être inspirer
ou nourrir le travail au Québec
je suis le directeur général de Hubert
pour le Québec si les représentants du
beurre espèrent qu'un changement de
ministre va faciliter les choses la
réalité est tout autre en commission
parlementaire le ministre Dao est
cinglant est-ce que vous venez nous dire
c'est tenter aussi longtemps que la loi
fera pas mon affaire je ne la respecte
pas pour moi monsieur c'est inacceptable
et vous n'êtes pas celui qui va nous
imposer le modèle écoutez
je vais repasser la prochaine question
j'ai pas de commentaire
Hubert craint le nouveau ministre
propose une loi qui ne fera pas son
affaire l'entreprise décéda alors de le
contourner lui aussi dans une lettre
adressée au Premier ministre Couillard
Hubert déplore que ses efforts pour
convaincre le ministre n'ont pas porté
fruits l'entreprise réclame de
rencontrer le Premier ministre avant de
dépôt du projet de loi le lobbyiste en
chef du beurre et ancien organisateur
d'Obama David plouf obtient un entretien
téléphonique avec le bureau du premier
ministre deux jours avant le dépôt du
projet de loi est-ce qu'il y avait des
communications d'informations
dans tous les groupes projets doigts
dans tous les projets de loi de tout
gouvernement
le 12 mai 2016 Jacques Daoud dépose son
projet de loi un projet qui vise à
légaliser uber mais tout en continuant à
limiter le nombre total de véhicules
pouvant offrir du transport de personnes
des chauffeurs de taxi eux poussent un
soupir de soulagement
donc on a essayé de cohabiter avec
on essaye de cohabiter avec et puis là
c'était une lueur d'espoir
mais cet espoir est de courte durée deux
jours plus tard pendant le Conseil
Général du Parti libéral à la
Drummondville le président de la
commission jeunesse Jonathan Marlo mène
une attaquant règles contre le projet de
loi non
notre rôle c'est en tant que
l'Assemblée et le Premier ministre
Couillard il fait un plaidoyer en faveur
d'une loi moins restrictive
la résolution sur l'économie on a été
soumis à une pression très très intense
non seulement de la Commission jeunesse
mais d'autres membres du parti je pense
que je me souviens bien j'avais même été
interpellé sur le parquet du conseil
général où on disait qu'il fallait
moderniser ça qu'il fallait avancer plus
vite et c'était facile de nous dépeindre
à ce moment-là comme étant des gens
rétrogrades ou réactionnaires qui
étaient pas capable de gérer le
changement et c'est ça la communication
qui a été réussie par uber à cette
époque les jeunes libéraux continuent
d'avoir des discussions avec Hubert en
coulisse confirme Jonathan Marleau on
voulait bien comprendre c'est quoi leur
vision à eux mais on ne voulait surtout
pas devenir un peu à leur service ou
quoi que ce soit parce que nous notre
focus c'était vraiment de s'assurer que
on a encore de ruban donc on voulait
voir aussi mais comment on les encadrer
tout en permettant à ce que des
compagnies québécoises puissent émerger
par la suite la Commission jeunesse
dépose ensuite un mémoire très critique
du projet de loi un cadeau tombe et du
ciel pour la coalition à venir Québec et
je cite le mémoire des jeunes libéraux
le projet de loi sang déposé par le
Gouvernement est un échec monsieur le
Président les jeunes libéraux ont fait
prendre un méchant coup de vieux au
gouvernement libéral il y a
avec l'appui de la CAQ Hubert estime que
ses chances de succès augmentent selon
un courriel interne mais pour éviter les
limites sur le nombre de chauffeurs qui
imposera la nouvelle loi Hubert se
cherche une porte de sortie
l'entreprise élabore une stratégie pour
convaincre le gouvernement de la laisser
poursuivre ses activités grâce à un
projet pilote
le fait de opérer un projet pilote ça
séduit de plus en plus de consommateurs
sur le plateforme et ça nous donnait un
levier contre les pouvoirs publics pour
leur dire vous voyez votre loi là elle
est pas bonne voilà suffisante
à la dernière minute un amendement au
projet de loi est adopté afin de mettre
en place un projet pilote pour uber
instaurant deux régimes un pour les
taxis et un autre moins contraignant
pour la multinationale américaine
écoutez moi le souvenir de ça c'est
qu'on est loin de leur abandonner ce
qu'il voulait en fait ils étaient pas du
tout content là je peux vous dire ça là
ils ont pas obtenu ce qu'ils soient fait
[Musique]
en 2018 la carte prend le pouvoir puis
l'année suivante adopte une nouvelle loi
qui légalise Hubert en éliminant
plusieurs des restrictions auxquelles
l'entreprise faisait encore face
c'est libéralisation de l'industrie du
taxi donc c'est c'est la fin de
l'édifice réglementaire qui existait
depuis
70 ce qui est clair c'est que
Hubert est arrivé à ses fins
donc il a transformé la réglementation
à sa mesure
après la pause l'arrivée du beurre
devait être une bonne chose pour les
clients et pour les chauffeurs mais
ils vont dire ça coûte moins cher c'est
facile
c'est rapide mais des fois la réalité
est tout autre des fois Hubert coûte
vraiment plus cher que les taxis
[Musique]
au final en promettant l'économie du
partage bonne pour les clients bonne
pour les chauffeurs Hubert a réussi à
complètement libéraliser l'industrie du
taxi mais à quel prix pour la population
la multinationale réussit à avoir Hubert
et l'argent du beurre
après avoir forcé sa venue au Québec
Hubert a transformé le paysage du
transport urbain
[Musique]
mais quelle est la réalité sur le
terrain
l'application est populaire et des
milliers de Québécois ont décidé
d'offrir leur service de chauffeur
je m'appelle Jean je suis chauffeur uber
depuis 5 ans moi je fais du beurre parce
que
c'est plus un habit
Jean-Gagnant est un contractuel pour un
cabinet de service professionnel de
Montréal il est aussi chauffeur Hubert à
temps partiel
[Musique]
je pense que
uber comme revenu d'appoint c'est
parfait comme deuxième travail c'est
parfait comme travail
principal c'est pas une vie facile
majoration c'est ici c'est une course
majorée voyez-vous un point 2
course majorée de 20% dans la vie d'un
chauffeur ouvert c'est pratiquement rien
ça m'intéresse pas
[Musique]
le coût d'un déplacement avec Hubert
varie selon l'offre et la demande pour
que ce soit rentable Jean ne sors de
chez lui que lorsque les ondes colorées
sur la carte indiquent des prix majorés
d'au moins le double le matin je me lève
je regarde la carte la plupart du temps
est-ce que c'est rouge oui c'est rouge
let's go on s'habille on se fait un café
rapidement puis on espère trouver une
course
lors de tempête de neige par exemple les
prix du Berre peuvent quadrupler récolte
à l'échante pour les chauffeurs mais une
facture salée pour les consommateurs ton
entreprise a peu fait mention dans sa
campagne de séduction
ils vont dire aux clients ça coûte moins
cher c'est facile
c'est rapide mais des fois la réalité
est tout autre des fois Hubert coûte
vraiment plus cher que les taxis
puis les clients des fois ils ont pas le
choix d'appeler
une course qui pourrait coûter 30
dollars des fois peut coûter 120$ c'est
de l'argent
[Musique]
uber voulais tout et son contraire il
voulait convaincre les consommateurs que
c'était le meilleur service pour le prix
le plus bas il voulait faire miroiter et
faire semblant faire croire au chauffeur
qu'ils allaient bien un gagnant leur vie
maintenant on voit la réalité en Europe
et ailleurs dans le monde que les
chauffeurs ils sont vraiment exploités
et donc quelque part on a vendu un
mensonge
pour sa part j'en Gagnon ne se sent pas
exploité mais il constate sur un forum
Facebook dont t'aider le modérateur que
bien des chauffeurs uber de Montréal qui
travaillent à temps plein se plaignent
de leurs conditions de travail
Hubert dit que le revenu médian des
chauffeurs à Montréal qui font plus de
20 heures par semaine et de 33 dollars
de l'heure ce nombre ne tient pas compte
des frais d'exploitation
Jean et diplômé DHC et suit de près ses
revenus et ses dépenses faire du Hubert
et devenu moins intéressant pour lui
récemment c'est un très bon en début de
2022 mais depuis trois quatre mois c'est
pas vraiment bon c'est pas aussi bon
tellement que j'ai arrêté d'en faire
pratiquement pourquoi parce qu'il y
avait plus de majoration je me retrouve
à faire un taux horaire de 25$ net
au cours des derniers mois Hubert dit
avoir vu le plus grand nombre
d'inscriptions de nouveaux chauffeurs au
Québec que l'entreprise enregistrée
depuis plusieurs années j'en considère
que c'est un flux de chauffeur contribue
à la diminution de leurs revenus ça ça
rentre désagréable parce que c'est moins
payant on se partage la même tarte c'est
chauffeur là demain des chauffeurs qui
ont proposé mettre une limite de
chauffeur mais là c'est comme le retour
à l'industrie du taxi la version 2.0
les propriétaires de taxis diseux aussi
qui est revenu sont plus maigres
qu'avant en raison de la croissance du
nombre de chauffeurs maintenant on ne
peut pas vivre en faisant seulement du
taxi on va faire du taxi à tapas ciel
de plus lorsque le gouvernement le goût
a légalisé uber il a mis fin au système
de permis qui permettait de contrôler le
nombre de véhicules dans l'industrie du
taxi c'est permis valait plus de 200000
dollars chacun avant cuber arrive sur le
marché québécois max Louis rosalbert
comptait louer son permis taxi afin
d'assurer ses vieux jours mais ce n'est
plus possible
c'était notre
mais avec la dernière loi que
gouvernement de
Monsieur LEGO avec prise la valeur de
première à 0 donc c'est dire que
nous n'avons plus de fonds de passion
plutôt que de profiter de sa retraite il
continue de faire du taxi pour soutenir
sa famille même à l'âge de 76 ans
il n'a reçu du gouvernement que montant
de 75000 dollars provenant d'un
programme de compensation mis sur pied à
la suite de l'élimination des permis de
taxis à l'échelle de la province ça
représente des dédommagements de plus de
800 millions de dollars nous sommes
colossales que le gouvernement récupère
petit à petit en imposant des frais d'un
dollar sur chaque trajet du Berre et de
taxi
c'est le consommateur qui dédommage
le business model du bain qui aide les
investisseurs ubains à faire concurrence
au taxi
si on dit nouvelle technologie dans une
industrie
c'est très cher payer pour l'ensemble de
la société québécoise
la campagne de lobbying du beurre a donc
frappé sa cible au Québec elle laisse
dans son sillage une industrie plus
moderne mais aussi des chauffeurs qui
peinent davantage à gagner leur vie
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié notre
reportage de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
je vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]